spider-man is speaking out at d23 Expo
2019 things haven't been easy lately for
actor Tom Holland he's had one of the
worst weeks an actor could have after
the unthinkable happened
news broke that Disney and Sony failed
to renegotiate their 2015 deal that
landmark agreement allowed Holland Sony
owned spider-man to appear in movies in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe earning
money for Sony while Marvel maintained
creative inputs if a new deal really
isn't being negotiated it means that
spider-man is leaving the MCU
in other words Holland's world got
flipped upside down his future with both
Marvel Studios and Sony Pictures was
called into question and his millions of
adoring fans wondered why he wasn't
speaking out about the situation one
would imagine that Holland a longtime
spider-man fan would be devastated over
the Disney's Sony divorce and apparently
there'd be mostly right Holland finally
broke his silence about the studio split
during d23 Expo on Saturday August 24th
taking the stage to promote his upcoming
movie onward a Pixar animated flick also
featuring Marvel favourite Chris Pratt's
Holland admitted that he's been having a
rough time since the news dropped and
he's trying to focus on what matters
most
though Holland didn't say much about the
corporate spat the message he did
deliver to his fans was an emotional one
it's been a crazy week but I want you to
know that I am grateful from the bottom
of my heart and I love you 3,000 the 23
year old actors candid admission is both
refreshing and heartbreaking and has
mentioned that he's genuinely thankful
for his fans and for the opportunity to
play spider-man over the years is enough
to make anyone shed a tear or two after
the presentation at d23 Holland spoke
with Entertainment Weekly about leaving
the MCU promising that he'll keep
stepping into the Spidey suit for as
long as he can and continue making the
franchise as great as it can be he told
the magazine basically we've made five
great movies it's been five amazing
years I've had the time of my life who
knows what the future holds but all I
know is that I'm going to continue
playing spider-man and having the time
of my life it's going to be so fun
however we choose to do it he added
optimistically the future for spider-man
will be different but it will be equally
as awesome and amazing and we'll find
new ways to make it even cooler Marvel
Studios President Kevin Feige who
produce both homecoming and far from
home also addressed the situation
echoing Holland with his own
optimistic viewpoints he said what I'm
feeling about spider-man is gratitude
and joy we got to make five films within
the MCU with spider-man two standalone
films and three with the Avengers it was
a dream that I never thought would
happen it was never meant to last
forever we knew there was a finite
amount of time that we'll be able to do
this and we told the story we wanted to
tell and I'll always be thankful for
that yeah but tell that to far from
homes cliffhanger ending in a perfect
world Holland would have never needed to
address at Disney Sony breaker because
it never would have happened if all that
gone the way everyone truly wanted it to
go the two companies would have been
able to reach an agreement to keep
spider-man in the MCU far from home
served as a conclusion for Marvel's
phase three and considering how much
emphasis the movie placed on spider-man
as a success at a Tony Stark
many were pondering the characters place
in the upcoming phase four and beyond
a third spider-man movie continuing
Peter Parker's story felt inevitable but
now that the character's connections to
the MCU have apparently been severed no
one knows what that movie is going to
look like before the news broke it felt
like Holland spider-man was going to
avoid the same fate as Andrew Garfield's
iteration of the character and what gets
a complete his trilogy and then some but
it looks like those assumptions were
wrong there's no telling what will
happen for Holland spiderman next but
one thing's for sure no matter what fans
will be telling the actor they love him
3,000 for years to come well maybe
tributes one everything's gonna work out
exactly it's just check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but the Marvel Cinematic
Universe are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and to the Bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]